entré à shirani c'est pénétrer dans les
secrets les plus sombres de l'ex union
soviétique en pleine forêt au bout de
cette route enneigée se cache qui fut
autrefois l'un des laboratoires les plus
mystérieux du pays
[Musique]
à l'apogée de la guerre froide
c'est ici que les armes chimiques les
poisons assassins ont été fabriquées et
entrepose c'est la ville des chimistes
pour la protection de la patrie prévient
la pancarte à l'entrée
et c'est pour la protéger des curieux
que shirani portait depuis des décennies
le steak de ville fermée
le checkpoint qu'on vient tout juste de
passer à quelques semaines seulement
quand il était ouvert y avait des gardes
à l'entrée et l'accès était vraiment
limité ou 5000 résidants russes qui
habitent ici à shirani à l'année longue
donc les étrangers comme nous était tout
simplement interdit d'accès aujourd'hui
la belle et tous les yeux doux
c'est tout nouveau mais vous allez voir
ya encore énormément méfiance on n'a pas
l'habitude des visites aux marchés du
centre
l'accueil est imé mais le dialogue il
fera je ne vous dirai rien des travaux
secret mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous étions bien payé le g et
on recevait d'y vivre de mossoul
c'étaient les belles années
malgré le communisme ici c'était le
paradis
à l'époque les chimistes joue un rôle
patriotique
cet ancien machine est il était aux
récompenses
vladimir fait dos au vent est un des
rares scientifiques qui habite toujours
le coin à 72 ans il se consacre
aujourd'hui à la musique et au théâtre
né en 1975 il était un jeune savant
venus de moscou pour travailler ou
laboratoire secret je travaillais dans
la recherche de nouvelles armes
chimiques et le développement d'agents
innervant mixte ni moralité jusqu'au 10
expérimenté avec ce qui sera plus tard
appelé le poison de [ __ ] up faisait
partie de sa réalité coop
c'était non seulement un devoir dit-il
mais une grande fierté
on savait que sa force mortelle était
dix fois plus grande que celle de son
équivalent américain vous dis
honnêtement que j'étais fier de ma
patrie se posait pas de question à
savoir si c'était bien ou pas bien à
barhoum la protection du pays et des
prioritaires
il demeure convaincu que le poison n'a
jamais quitté le laboratoire et que tous
les stocks ont été détruits dans cadre
du programme d'élimination des armes
chimiques
signé après la chute de l'union
soviétique puis en mars dernier à plus
de 4000 kilomètres d'ici au royaume uni
la sphère skripal a éclaté selon les
services de renseignement britanniques
c'est au laboratoire de sheerani que le
novice choc utilisé pour empoisonner
l'ex espion et sa fille aurait été
concocté qui déchira ni dino vite choc
explique le maire ça fait un an que le
téléphone sonne et lieu désormais
profiter de l'ouverture de la ville pour
exploiter cette étrange notoriété
toujours
il évoque même la possibilité de faire
breveter le nom du célèbre poison pour
une compagnie qui fait dans
l'extermination animal humour noir
détresse économique
ça en dit long sur son désir de réanimer
la région
le village n'a ni restaurants et cafés
et depuis cuisine a cessé ses activités
en 1993 la qualité vie ne cesse de
dégringoler
on se moque de nous cette femme nous
avons sacrifié notre santé à l'usiné et
maintenant on a besoin d'être soigné il
ne restait que cinq lits à l'hôpital
gaston joignait on avale me tenir à
voter hier le docteur bladimir saviez
liège et pino mollo fils est
particulièrement inquiet des maladies
tardive qui l'observent si d'anciens
employés
il y à des cancers du cerveau des
infections pulmonaires des sarcomes ce
sont des bombes à retardement illescas
explose depuis les dix dernières années
c'est très difficile de prouver le lien
car il n'existe aucune statistique
on ignore même si le sol est contaminé
la ville qui fut à l'époque la grande
fierté de l'état semble aujourd'hui
sombrer dans l'oubli
non moi je projette l'ouverture de la
ville c'est comme une nouvelle liberté
mais qu'est ce qu'on va en faire dix
sept jeunes femmes
c'est à nous les jeunes de la rode
prospère imaginez l oms présent et mine
de rien c'est la toute première fois
qu'elle s'adresse à des étrangers reboot
edf camille guermonprez d'autres
personnes ne vient ici personne ils nous
promettent des investissements mais qui
va investir ici octobre près d'y
investir dans quoi on ne peut même pas
développer l'agriculture
je vous le dis les gens sont condamnés
et d'avocats
vous imaginez
[Musique]
la dîmière souffre lui aussi d'une
maladie chronique des poumons
mais l'ignorent qui va le soigner dans
l'avenir
aujourd'hui shirani n'a plus rien à
cacher même pas son désespoir et sa
nostalgie
[Musique]